hola de nuevo bueno en el vídeo pasado
lo tuve que dejar porque estaba
rebasando el tiempo permitido en youtube
pero ya estamos de regreso estábamos con
el coseno de menos a entonces dibuje yo
un triángulo rectángulo con un ángulo
con un ángulo a luego te mostré menos a
y todas las longitudes serían iguales
también estamos asumiendo estar en el
círculo unitario y si no recuerdas el
círculo unitario tenemos vídeos de eso
también así que echarles un vistazo pero
solo te muestro que el coste no de menos
an es igual a este lado sobre la
hipotenusa ahora bien esta hipotenusa es
la misma que esta hipotenusa entonces
coseno de menos a es adyacente sobre
esta hipotenusa mientras que coseno de a
es adyacente sobre esta hipotenusa pero
es lo mismo entonces sabemos que coseno
de menos a es igual a coseno de an y de
hecho por definición eso asia coseno una
función par aún de hecho sería muy buena
idea hacer una presentación sobre
funciones pares e impares de hecho me
suena muy bien ahora veamos qué es seno
de menos a seno de menos an es igual
entonces bueno este lado es este lado
bueno para
confundirte aquí llamemos a esto
llamemos a esto llamémosle x x y a esto
ya vemos que la hipotenusa la dejamos
igual si esto es x esto es por lo tanto
esta longitud es menos x cierto por lo
tanto aquí tenemos menos seno de a es
igual a menos x sobre h - x sobre h y
ahora cuál es el seno de a el seno de a
es igual a opuesto sobre hipotenusa
entonces x sobre h muy bien hasta aquí
ahora el seno de menos a es igual a
menos 1 por x sobre h o lo que es lo
mismo si multiplicamos ambos lados por
un menos uno tenemos menos x sobre h
cierto así que lo hacemos menos y menos
x sobre h por lo tanto seno de menos a
es igual a menos seno de a menos seno de
a y bueno muy bien hasta aquí ahora voy
a dejar en claro todo porque no quiero
que queden dudas voy a reescribir esta
identidad como tú puedes ver lo único
que estoy haciendo es simplemente jugar
con los triángulos
y mostrarte que el shock actúa en su
cara puedes descubrir un conjunto todo
un conjunto de identidades
trigonométricas si sabes el soca está
ahí y también bueno muchas de estas
identidades es bueno memorizar las claro
porque son cosas que vas a necesitar
tener a la mano de ya en algún momento
son muy importantes pero también me
gustaría que en dado caso de no saber la
de memoria puedas llegar a ellas me
interesa que puedas y sepas cómo
probarlo cómo probar las identidades si
algún día tienes que enseñar las lo
puedes hacer así que voy a borrar esto y
veamos si podemos descubrir más
identidades trigonométricas entonces
aquí ok
ahora muy bien que teníamos teníamos que
el pse no vamos a tomar aquí al seno de
a más piso de dos valen a veces eso es
interesante porque porque podemos usar
la identidad de seno de a más velas
recuerdas la cual ya probamos entonces
podemos usar la que nos decía esa
identidad no sabemos que el seno de ea
más b bueno en esta forma tendría el
seno de a más y sobre 2
se ha multiplicado por el co seno de mi
sobre 2
y sobre dos más
el seno de pi sobre 2
sobre dos y bueno de hecho claro estamos
en radiales sería lo mismo que 90 grados
cierto si habláramos en grados entonces
seno de pi sobre 2 por el coseno de a y
esto es igual a seno de an y que es
coseno de pi sobre dos es coseno de 90
es lo mismo en el ciclo unitario coseno
de 90 apunta directamente hacia arriba
así que la coordenada x vale 0 puedes
dibujar de hecho el círculo unitario
para comprobarlo o haz una calculadora
para pero aprenderás que vale 0 y más
senodep y sobre 2 por la misma razón
está apuntando directamente hacia arriba
en el círculo unitario entonces la
coordenada james vale 1
de hecho en el círculo unitario es el
punto 0 1 este que estamos hablando
entonces seno de piso de 12 es 1 luego
multiplicado por el coste no de ahora
sino de a por 0 eso es cero más uno por
coseno de esco seno de a simplemente así
que aquí tenemos otra identidad
trigonométricas wow ok ahora tenemos que
el seno vea más pi sobre dos es igual al
coseno de a fascinante fascinante está
genial porque esto porque porque esto lo
que nos dice es simplemente que el coste
no de a es lo mismo que el seno de ha
trasladado si pensamos en esto
gráficamente si dibujáramos la gráfica
si trasladamos la gráfica de seno a la
izquierda en pi sobre 2 obtenemos el
coste lo obtenemos la gráfica del coseno
así que si no has aprendido de hecho de
trata ciones no te preocupes anímate a
graficar esto a graficar ambas funciones
y todo esto tendrá tendrá mucho más
sentido así que otra manera de escribir
esto
sería que el seno de a es igual a coseno
de a menos pi sobre dos entonces seno de
ea es igual a coseno de a menos pi sobre
dos y si tú simplemente digamos que yo
dije que estoy aquí es igual a b así que
lo pongo acá es igual a más y sobre 2
entonces podríamos decir que esto que
esto es cierto y entonces esto sería de
menos pi sobre 2 y bueno no te quiero
confundir simplemente te quiero mostrar
que muchas de estas trigonometría es
sencillamente descubrimiento juzgar con
lo que ya se conoce exacto es jugar
ahora que es el seno de a menos b el
seno de al menos ver bueno esto parece
ser una nueva una nueva identidad cierto
lo que vamos a llegar ahora veamos hoy
voy a intentar averiguar a qué es igual
esto esto es igual al seno de a por el
coste no de menos b
más
más el seno de menos b
por el coseno de a pero que sabemos que
sabemos de coseno de menos de antes de
cambiario la pantalla ya lo habíamos
hecho el coste no debe nos ven como es
una función para el coche no es lo mismo
que coste no deben así que podemos
escribir esto esto se no esto es igual
al seno de a
por el coche no debe y ahora que es el
seno de menos b es lo mismo que menos el
seno de b eso lo acabamos de probar de
hecho hace hace unos minutos cierto
entonces esto es igual a menos el seno
de b
puedes dibujar el triángulo en el
círculo unitario para comprobarlo pero
lo acabamos de hacer entonces eso es
igual a menos el seno de b por el coseno
de a interesante cierto y de hecho
anímate a hacer lo mismo con el coseno
de a menos 20 am eso sería muy bueno que
lo hicieras estamos usando una o dos o
tres identidades que ya conocemos y
estamos llegando a nuevas identidades
así que bueno de hecho creo que hasta
este punto hemos llegado o hemos ya
visto las identidades trigonométricas
básicas y bueno creo que con esto ya
puedes llegar a varias más más
identidades y si sigues moviéndole
jugando aquí con lo que ya tenemos hasta
el momento y obviamente todas estas
identidades puedes invertir en ellas los
senos los cosenos las tangentes y vas a
obtener nuevas basadas va a obtener
nuevas para la secante para la cosa
para la tangente y también de hecho te
invito a que lo hagas gráficamente eso
sería muy bueno también sería muy buena
idea que dibujar as el seno de a más pi
sobre dos en el futuro haré un vídeo
donde veremos todo eso pero mientras
llegue ese día haz lo intenta lo intenta
hacerlo espero tengas éxito y también
espero no haberte confundido con con
tantas a todo esto que dice am sólo
quería que vieras que te dieras cuenta
de que mucha trigonometría viene del
soca tohá porque jugando con el soca
toay con triángulos puede llegar a
cualquier identidad te lo aseguro
pero bueno en fin espero esto te haya
servido y nos vemos pronto
bye